here's my eyes I see wish finish manalo
as he smiled as i say ich kann ich mich
Toph I office nice summer for Emma funny
session sky vs allosaurs I realized on a
stage time my name is I'm iliff i come
from Berlin and I'm a singer-songwriter
a 2013-single by alif courts why Honda
Targa's AMA 200 days of summer alif is a
native speaker of German unlike her
parents [ __ ] sentence and my
grandparents came to Germany from a
village near adana sometime in the late
1970s early 80s and they brought my dad
with them sometime later when he was
back in Turkey he fell in love with my
mother and brought her to Germany and i
was born in berlin not our chunk of wood
for easton acaba open and billion
nonsens even answers cleanest offi metal
mill to Philippe session mama I inertia
Peter Burley entire session ii the story
of her family was among the themes
covered on a Leafs 2013 debut album
hunter miner out under my skin as a
teenager Elif had to fight for every
piece of freedom like many other teens
religion was important to her Muslim
parents but other matters took priority
in a Leafs life as far munch my guns cut
waters sometimes it was pretty stormy
sometimes really loud sometimes very
quiet everybody was very happy and then
really sad won't I think that's just
part of this Turkish culture I've
noticed myself how I can really blow
something up that has to do with
temperament although I'm nowhere near as
temperamental as my parents immense at
one who buys a few vinegar temperament
as mine Aaron Elif Demi Reza draws
inspiration for her lyrics from daily
life as well as from German offers
elif grew up bilingual and knew early on
that she wanted to sing in German even
if it isn't the easiest language for pop
music is a severe it's so hard to say
something joyful in german deutsch and
even harder to sing it if you say are
saying i love you it doesn't have much
force this guy in a German song you have
to reformulate it if it's a love song
that can be a real challenge this is in
view notice to get house for home as
refugees keep arriving in Germany they
encounter demonstrations and active
resistance to them and the German
government's policy including arson
attacks on reception centers and
shelters events that have affected alif
to last much of hidden files what really
shocks me is that the right wing
movement keeps getting bigger to judge
by the media reports i think what i can
do is just help out donate clothing and
ease the fears of people who are afraid
assure them that everything will turn
out alright and nobody will take
anything away from them there's enough
for everyone especially in Germany is
asking for a luda for a lemon
Deutschland
alif also a keen runner sees her roots
in two different worlds as an enrichment
not as a problem
if kagaz my net also that my parents
come from Turkey while I was born here
mostly concerns other people it doesn't
really interest me because I am what I
am whether I live in France or Los
Angeles I'll always just be me if I saw
a big deal sta monica no big deal her
ambition is to write timeless songs now
Elif is at work on her second album
buddy's big deal gone up your phone your
mother from Samuel
I love the fish dishes